hallo mein Name ist Luca
[Musik]
und ihr seht schon ich habe uns hier so
eine kleine süße Kerze angebracht denn
das heutige Video wird extrem entspannt
ich habe euch nach ein paar Fragen auf
Instagram gefragt und die habt ihr mir
eingesendet von daher beantworte ich dir
jetzt fliegen Autos so schnell wie
Giraffen
danke für eure Fragen was war dein
verstörendster Traum also mein
verstörendster albtrauben war als ich
von einem Mörder mit der Stream Maske
mit einem Messer in einer Holzfabrik
verfolgt wurde und mein generell
verstörender Traum war als ich in einer
Wüste war auf einem Elch geritten bin
und diesen Elch dann gegessen habe
fragt einfach nicht bist du mit deinem
momentanen Youtube Status bzw stand
zufrieden nein
das soll jetzt nicht unankbar klingen
aber ich war auch noch nie mit meinem
youtube-status oder stand zufrieden weil
ich auch irgendwo leider gesehen ein
Mensch bin der nie wirklich komplett zu
100% zufrieden ist kommt ein Minecraft
Staffel 3 Projekt
stellt euch mal einen Wecker auf morgen
18 Uhr
und schaut dann mal auf meinem
YouTube-Kanal vorbei hallo Luca mal eine
Frage was denn eigentlicher Traumberuf
war oder ist ich wollte schon immer
Architekt werden und ich möchte auch
jetzt immer noch Architekt werden und
ich glaube ich hätte auch an diesem
Beruf so blöd das jetzt klingt wirklich
mehr Spaß als an diesem ganzen Youtube
Krams aber ich weiß auch dass mir
Architektur dann wahrscheinlich ein
bisschen zu stressig wäre auf Dauer und
dass ich dann diesen Youtube Bums wieder
vermissen würde wann Luca Pizza 4 es ist
realtalk aktuell gar nichts geplant was
vermisst du
viele Dinge aktuell aber ich glaube wenn
ich mich entscheiden müsste dann
wirklich Struktur in meinem Leben wie
geht es dir momentan in
99,9% der Fälle Antworten Leute mit gut
auf die Frage wie geht's dir
aber wenn ich sie ehrlich beantworten
müsste würde ich dir sagen mir geht's
aktuell überhaupt nicht gut
ich arbeite daran dass mir wieder besser
geht und ich bin auf einem guten Weg
aber ich muss ganz ganz viele Sachen
gerade rausfinden in meinem Leben und
es wäre gelogen wenn ich jetzt einfach
sagen würde mir geht's gut current
favorite song ich kann kein Englisch was
würdest du tun wenn Youtube für ein Jahr
gesperrt wäre ich hätte zum ersten Mal
richtig Urlaub wie läuft es mit dem
Sport aktuell sehr sehr sehr sehr gut
ich bin richtig happy weil ich jetzt
endlich dieses mindset habe dass ich
wirklich wirklich durchziehen will dass
ich die extra Runde drehen will die
extra Wiederholung machen dass ich keine
Ausreden mehr Suche und mich nicht
weiter im Kreis drehe sondern wirklich
durchziehe ich weiß ihr macht euch alle
mal lustig über meine Beine aber auch da
bin ich bei mir am arbeiten und mir geht
sehr sehr gut und sport trägt wirklich
nicht nur psychisch zu der Gesundheit
sehr sehr gut mit dabei sondern auch
physisch einfach schon mal drüber
nachgedacht mit Sandra zusammenzukommen
nein und werde ich auch nie das schönste
Erlebnis bei deinem letzten Urlaub ich
habe eine Kellnerin im Restaurant
kennengelernt und zu Beginn hatte man
nur ganz normalen Smalltalk aber über
eine halbe Stunde hat man sich dann
unterhalten und die hat alles mögliche
einem anvertraut und hat uns dann über
ihre Herz-OP erzählt er hat uns nachher
noch so ein shot ausgetan und war extrem
zuvorkommend und freundlich und einfach
so ein herzensguter auf einer Mensch und
das finde ich sind viel schönere
Erinnerungen an einem Urlaub all zu
sagen boah da war richtig tolles Wetter
so das war ein schönes Erlebnis hast du
vor noch mal umzuziehen also ihr wisst
ja das Auswandern für mich überhaupt
nicht in Frage kommt ich bin sehr sehr
glücklich hier in Deutschland ich würde
allerhöchstens vielleicht so in die
Schweiz gehen oder so allerdings
hinsichtlich Umzug bin ich erstmal
wirklich ganz zufrieden hier in Köln
freust du dich auf die Wok WM der ein
oder andere hat vielleicht schon
mitbekommen und zwar bin ich am
Samstagabend um 20:15 Uhr live auf
ProSieben zu sehen mit dieser verdammten
Wok WM mitmache und damit zum mit seiner
Pfanne eine Berg runter fahr mit 100 kam
ich weiß auch nicht was wir damit
gedacht haben wie ist das ohne Freundin
es ist anders
ich kann jetzt nicht sagen es ist besser
gerade Single zu sein als noch als ich
in einer Beziehung war ich kann auch
nicht sagen es ist schlecht da und ich
sehne mich wieder zurück in einer
Beziehung was ich aber nicht möchte ist
dass ich aktuell einen neuen Menschen
auf
beziehungsbasis gesehen kennenlerne weil
das haben wir auch viele dass sie sich
dann so in der kälteren Jahreszeit
einsam fühlen und keine Ahnung was aber
ich
[Musik]
ja bin da aktuell nicht auf der Suche
was ist dein bester Tipp um erfolgreich
zu werden es kommt natürlich auf den
Bereich an also wenn du mit YouTube
erfolgreich sein möchtest kann ich dir
nur sagen sei du selbst weil das ist
immer das realste und das ist
schlussendlich das was bei den Leuten
gut ankommt und auf irgendeine andere
Branche bezogen habe ich ja vorhin schon
gesagt im Thema Sport drehe diese extra
Runde zeig deinem Chef ey du bist eine
Stunde länger da als die anderen oder
auch wenn du Böden wischst oder am
Fließband stehst dann sei der verdammt
noch mal beste darin in deiner Arbeit in
deiner Tätigkeit die du machst gehst du
immer noch zur Therapie das ist
eine schwierige Frage weil ich warte
aktuell wirklich seit Wochen bei vielen
Ansprechpartnern hier in Köln mit
zugetragen wurden und empfohlen wurden
auf Termine weil das was ich habe ist
jetzt nichts dringliches dummes klingt
allerdings mache ich ganz viel so
online-sitzungen so Zoom calls mit
psychotrainern Therapeuten und das tut
extrem gut und halt einfach reden mit
engen Leuten ich habe ganz viel Kontakt
wieder zu Leuten mit denen ich vor acht
Jahren so mäßig zur Schule gegangen bin
und er hat dass mir das gut tut 900
November schon verkackt am zweiten Tag
ja größte Angst ich glaube dass diese
Frage in fast jedem Q&A von mir bisher
vorkam ich habe sie auch jedes Mal
gleich beantwortet meine größte Angst
ist es dass Menschen von mir gehen die
mir etwas bedeuten neues Auto was ist
mit deinem Turbo S ich habe meinen Turbo
S verkauft nach in München weil ich ein
Angebot bekommen habe was einfach fast
genauso hoch war wie der Preis den ich
vor zweieinhalb Jahren da gezahlt hatte
deswegen konnte ich eigentlich nicht
nein sagen und habe im Gegenzug auch
noch eine GT3 Quote und top bekommen für
den 992 GT3 und jeder von euch der sich
gleich ein bisschen auskennt der weiß
dass das so ca das schwierigste Auto zu
bekommen ist was es gibt deswegen war
ich unfassbar happy darüber dass ich
dieses Privileg hatte so eine Quote zu
bekommen und habe dann halt zugeschlagen
und ich bin so unfassbar glücklich mit
diesem Auto ich fahre zwar echt selten
Auto hier in der Stadt eigentlich immer
mit dem Fahrrad und außerhalb eigentlich
immer mit der Bahn aber wenn ich mal
Auto fahre bin ich echt immer noch so am
grinsen wie so ein kleines Kind hast du
noch Panikattacken ja
seid mir schwierig heute bei so ein paar
Themen darüber zu reden und ehrlich zu
sein aber irgendwo fühlt sich auch gut
an ein Kumpel von mir hatte vor ein paar
Wochen gesagt und das fand ich sehr
interessant dass er mehr Leute in
unserem Berufsfeld so in der
Öffentlichkeit kennt die Panikattacken
haben oder schon mal damit zu tun hatten
als sollte dies nicht hatten und ich
glaube wenn ich dann ganz normalen Job
hätte und mein to five dann hätte ich
das alles nicht aber dadurch dass diese
ganze Geschichte immer im Kopf hängt ist
das psychisch echt anstrengend und dann
ist es logisch dass es auch mal zu
Panikattacken kommen kann würdest du
noch mal was mit Jeremy fragrance machen
hundertprozentig
er hat natürlich Ansichten die ein
bisschen
realitätsfern sind aber erst an sich
echt ein guter Kerl und unterhaltsam auf
einem ganz anderen Level wann holst du
dir endlich einen Hund nach dem Sommer
habe ich ja gesagt ich hole mir auf
jeden Fall dieses Jahr noch einen Hund
und ich hätte am liebsten jetzt hier so
einen kleinen Goldie oder so Australian
Shepherd oder so neben mir sitzen aber
ich habe noch Bücher bestellt zum Thema
Hunde und ich bin ganz ehrlich ich werde
definitiv kein Hund holen wenn ich noch
hier in Köln in der Großstadt in der
Wohnung lebe das heißt es wird definitiv
noch Jahre dauern oder wenn ich halt in
ein Haus hier mit Garten will ich einen
Hund habe soll er das beste Leben
kriegen was er irgendwie kriegen kann
und das hat er hier nicht wenn er
rausgeht und er ist nur Beton so mäßig
wie viel Geld hast du insgesamt so ca
verdient jeder der mich schon ein
bisschen länger kennt weiß wie ich zu
diesem ganzen hey so viel Geld habe ich
verdient bisher mit YouTube Thema stehe
und zwar dass ich da wirklich absolut
gar nichts von halte
soll ja jeder machen wie er möchte kann
jeder über das reden was er verdient und
keine Ahnung was aber ich rede auch
wirklich nicht mit meinen Freunden da
jetzt groß drüber weil ich finde das ist
niemandem irgendetwas bringt klar dann
habt ihr Gewissheit und ihr wisst jetzt
boah luca hat hier 20 Millionen in
diesem Jahr verdient oder hat jetzt nur
1000 € in in dem Jahr verdient oder
irgendwas einfach wird Zahlen die ich
hier reingeworfen habe und es bringt
halt einfach niemandem etwas weil
entweder man ist dann halt neidisch oder
sauer auf diese Person wenn man sich
denkbar mit zum Krams verdienter so viel
Geld oder ihr denkt euch hey ich habe
gedacht das wäre viel mehr in jeglicher
Hinsicht ist es einfach nicht
zielführend und ich will nicht darauf
beschränkt werden oder da danach
beurteilt werden von wegen wie viel Geld
ich verdiene oder was ich habe oder was
ich mache oder keine Ahnung was das ist
eine Ansicht die ich da ziemlich Glück
und klar Vertreter wann machst du einen
roomtour sobald alles fertig ist und es
waren vor ein paar Tagen habt ihr auch
meine Instagram Story gesehen äh noch
mal ein paar Handwerker hier vor Ort bei
mir in der Wohnung in Köln allerdings
gibt's immer noch so ein paar Baustellen
die noch nicht ganz durch sind kannst du
mal wieder goat Simulator spielen
nächste Woche
Simulator 3 raus also dann kommen
regelmäßig wieder goat Simulator Videos
weil dann müssen wir uns die komplette
neue Map und das komplette neue Spiel
wieder angucken hast du irgendwelche
Ziele zum Beispiel vegan werden in ein
anderes Land ziehen etc das Thema
Auswandern hatten wir gerade schon und
vegan werden steht jetzt auch nicht ganz
oben auf meiner bucket List ich ähm
verzichte immer mehr auf Fleisch und
esse was wirklich Fleisch angeht nur
noch ab und zu wirklich
Hähnchenbrustfilet und Fisch mag ich
halt total gern das ist schwierig für
mich da drauf zu verzichten allerdings
ist wirklich mein Hauptziel und das auch
noch am liebsten für dieses Jahr dass
ich wieder richtig richtig glücklich bin
und ich weiß ihr seht mich wenn ich auf
Videos reagiere oder wenn ich die Tage
dann vielleicht auch wieder Minecraft
spiele seht ihr mich glaube ich schon
glücklich aber das ist alles nur
Ablenkung und wenn ich wirklich allein
abends mein Bett liege bin ich
eigentlich nicht glücklich wie stehst du
zu lgbtq+ Community total beschissen
ey sorry aber ich verstehe solche Fragen
nicht also no joke das ist es gibt da ja
keine zwei Meinungen das ist genauso wie
stehst du zum Thema Mobbing oder
irgendwie sowas es gibt keine zwei
Meinungen bei solchen Fragen und jeder
der eine andere Meinung hat das ist
einfach nur [ __ ] so sorry aber es
ist halt einfach so meine Ansicht nach
soll jeder Mensch das machen können so
aussehen können sich so sexuell ausleben
können oder keine Ahnung was machen
können wie er Bock hat wie er lustig ist
ich
beurteile eine Menschen nicht wie er auf
was steht oder wie aus oder keine Ahnung
was sondern wir mir gegenüber ist mehr
jemand zu mir ein Wixxer ist dann ist es
mir egal was der für eine Hautfarbe hat
oder auf was für ein Geschlecht er steht
oder keine Ahnung was dann finde ich den
einfach scheiße aber wenn jemand korrekt
zu mir ist damit ich auch korrekt zu
dieser Person dann ist es mir auch
scheißegal was er irgendwie im
Hintergrund oder woher der kommt oder
was weiß ich und das
ich habe sogar voll viele Fragen aber
komm lass mir das als Schluss Punkt ich
bin in der oder bei 40 Minuten das ist
ein Übel langes Video jetzt geworden
aber ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen wir
sehen uns morgen um 18 Uhr hier auf
unserem Kanal wieder auf unserem Kanal
auf meinem Kanal es ist ja quasi unser
Kanal aber so vom Ding ja morgen 18 Uhr
müsste auf jeden Fall einschalten wenn
euch dieses Video gefallen hat lasst
einen Daumen hoch unter diesem Video da
abonniert meinen Kanal und klickt auf
die Glocke damit ihr dieses Video morgen
um 18 Uhr nicht verpasst stellt euch
einen Wecker und folgt mir auf Instagram
wenn ihr bei der nächsten Dienstag dabei
sein wollt ne tschüss